everyone always makes a joke about that
time Daigo cuz he would just study you
find out your weaknesses in the feejee
so as long as you give him time to study
he's always gonna win he sees Daigo as
like the number one right like the
number one person he's chasing to be
better than not as a player he doesn't
care about success or winning
championships and you can see how much
it affected him to put everything he had
in the set and then still lose that's
one thing I want to say fighting game is
something so great
[Applause]
hey folks before we get into the meat of
the video I just wanna remind you to
please sub to the channel if you haven't
already if you want to see more great
fun and game videos like this or any
kind of videos that we do a sub really
does mean a lot anyway
if you know anything about fighting
games you've heard of Tokita oh no the
murderface too early
and he's up in front of the screen that
is unprecedented and Kay Brad's like did
that just happen
he's one of the most successful fighting
game players of all time with more
Street Fighter 5 trophies and top eight
finishes than anyone else in the world
and in 2017 he took home his first main
stage Evo trophy cementing his legacy as
one of the best to ever do it taquito
was on top of the world but in his mind
he was still chasing his greatest rival
Daigo ice Inc oh now I want to challenge
die goal because five years ago I was
but I okay I'm good but I'm not the best
but now I can show my best then I
challenge him let's go back in time a
bit these days most fighting game
tournaments play best two out of three
sets or three out of five in some cases
but that wasn't always the case
see back in the days of arcade fighting
games you stayed on the machine as long
as you were winning and when two great
players faced off they played as long as
set as they can manage one of the
reasons why a lot of people like first
intents are kind of you know treat them
as and super important is because it
gives people a chance to adjust and it
makes sure that you know they people
feel like it's more accurate in terms of
who's a better player so I do think
force attends is definitely a myth I
guess a you know magical thing where it
will prove that I am better than you at
now right now and then the person losing
the first ten it's gonna go back home
that's salty you know and then they go
back you know I need to find a way to
kind of like figure this out so I could
win next time and in the world of super
long first two ten sets
no one was better than Daigo Umehara
Daigo earned his nickname the Beast
during his rise to fgc superstardom in
the 90s and early 2000
and by the 2010s he was more than just
the best player in the world he was a
legend from the most famous play in
fighting games
[Applause]
to being the first person in Japan to be
sponsored for playing video games
effectively making him the grandfather
of Japanese eSports and though he wasn't
winning back-to-back Evo's like he was
when Street Fighter 4 came out Daigo was
still unstoppable when you gave him time
to prepare everyone always makes the
joke about prep times I go and so when
he's given an opportunity to know who
his opponent is and study them and
figure out what their weaknesses are and
how to beat them it's just very very
potent and it's hard to beat a person
with that kind of mindset that he has
meanwhile tokino was well he was great
but he wasn't a star he was known as a
jack-of-all-trades
great at any fighting game he touched
but a true master of none meanwhile
Daigo was the single best Street Fighter
4 player in the world and he proved it
in 2013
Daigo faced off against the defending
Evo champion infiltration to prove which
of them was truly the best the event was
called Mad Catz unveiled and they would
face off in a first to 10 match at Tokyo
Game Show but before the match
Daigo brought in Tokyo to get over to
practicing for the Akuma matchup the day
before much kizomba he asked me let's
practice
then he beat he destroyed me
it was a most shocked experience for me
it's same human kind
but he's another level and the next day
I goes match against infiltration wasn't
even close
you know we're witnessing two things
here we're witnessing and tested like Oh
skill but also Tokyo's ability to teach
very convincing went here and while
Daigo was obliterating infiltration ten
to two Tokyo was rethinking his life it
was five years ago
he beat me very bad so I had to change
my mind I have to be at least I want to
be the best or I couldn't survive in the
fighting game community with them I I
completely changed my mind
I stopped playing any other fighting
games and I stick to play only one game
even though no one saw it
taquitos lost to Daigo was a wake-up
call it made him change everything from
the way he practiced to the way he'll it
yeah Toby otherwise there what kind of
hang car stuff there I thought my fedora
tips you got another message there what
I proposed also many call tonight
underneath a rock at all so no Jimmy
thirty-nine up till the room or its
keister think of a field or they got a
tip for the llamas on da pinkest I only
me until you know cannot although Tokyo
remade his entire life all so he could
become the best all so he could beat
Daigo I want to show my effort by be the
best player for me so it's it's Daigo
yes and my name is you know Hajime
Hajime is one yes my grandfather's name
me become number one and all those
changes paid off Tokyo spent the next
four years winning just about everything
he'd accomplished anything a
professional fighting game player could
ever hope for
that's gonna do it so Kido you're Canada
Cup 29
Street Fighter 5 champion he was even a
world champion that's one thing I want
to say biking game it's something so
great and yet while the confetti was
raining down and the crowd was chanting
his name taquito wasn't satisfied he
still had one more opponent to beat she
still had to face duygu the stage was
set
Takeda would face off against Daigo in a
first attend at kimono michi guy goes
show mash series both players hit the
lab studying each other's matches but
Daigo took things a step further first
Daigo found a young up-and-coming Akuma
player Otani and took him under his wing
helping him improve even teaching him to
play more like Tokita
and then tygo spent day after day
destroying him meanwhile the height was
building for the show match so you know
da da da [ __ ] haha Dixon this is a no
cookie another nanny or what there what
model you're going to stare have to get
me to equal the
the bottle - you're drinking a
particularly nice one well if Kimiko sec
we're taking me to her more - picking it
as well because you wanna put each
option under control opposite
what's Congo should have you still go
there goes hiking over 100 quid some
[ __ ] it all up over 50 o clock so
conjuring up dick - ha gentle rock based
on a recent tournament performances
everyone figure - Aikido was kind of a
walk he had just won evo and you can
never underestimate
Daigo crushed taquito ten to five
taquito just didn't have an answer for
die goes new innovative guile play style
and die go proved that with preparation
in a long set he's untouchable taquito
had been outperforming Daioh in
tournaments for years now but on that
stage the one he'd worked so hard to
reach he was nowhere near die goes club
he sees die go as like the number one
right like the number one person that
he's chasing to be better than not as a
player he doesn't care about like
success or winning championships in like
comparison to him but as he is as like a
model player and how like he basically
went to die goes court he was like he is
known to be the best in long sets
against really good opponents so for me
to be better than him I need to win
championships I need to study hard I
need to be like a face of the community
and I need to be better than him at like
what he's the best thing right so he set
his goals like extremely high in trying
to be Daigo in that set and you can see
how much it affected him to put
everything he had in the set and then
still lose obviously there's like that
Hill that he can't pass the kid passed I
go in that regards in his mind taquito
was devastated
so here food only is saying he this is
painful for him to watch - he's Ithaca
was incredibly strong and that lost for
taquito hurts Fudo as well as Tokyo you
can see it all over his face Tokyo knew
that if he wanted to reach the i-gos
level he would have to keep on climbing
so he threw himself back into his
training two years after their epic
clash
Daigo in Tokyo were set to face off
again it wasn't quite a first attend but
they presented Tokyo with an opportunity
a real serious long set against Daigo
with the entire world watching you know
oh you're my job
okay
it was really not dicta laughter but the
skin
[Music]
[Music]
taquito
finally reached the top of the mountain
he'd been climbing for nearly a decade
he finally beaten Daigo and it wasn't
even close he was finally the best today
taquito has accomplished everything he's
ever set out to do he's the face of
Street Fighter
he's an Evo champion he's got his own
personal sponsor he's defeated his rival
he's become a legend and the world will
never forget his name thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and bring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
you